merci Valérie Boyer d'être avec nous
pendant cette première demi-heure et lui
des bouches-du-rhônement du groupe les
républicains vous êtes rapporteurs du
texte pour garantir le respect du droit
à l'image des enfants on va en parler
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité on l'a vu dans le journal
c'est ce texte immigration qui
finalement va revenir au mois de juillet
c'est ce qui a demandé Elisabeth borne à
Gérald Darmanin c'est une bonne nouvelle
oui enfin on insiste malheureusement sur
un sujet pour lesquels 82 % des Français
sont d'accord 82% de selon les sondages
pour mettre fin au cas où migratoire que
le gouvernement a gravé parce que c'est
de ça dont il s'agit la loi collant a
été une catastrophe et je rappelle
qu'elle a été votée sous Macron 1 après
5 ans de Macron Hollande ou
l'immigration à prospérer et ensuite
depuis le début de ce deuxième
quinquennat Emmanuel Macron est dans une
posture totalement inerte face aux
difficultés majeures que rencontrent les
Français sur ce sujet donc si on veut
avoir un sujet de consensus si on va
avoir une majorité aujourd'hui c'est
bien sur le texte immigration
malheureusement ça ressemble à running
gag on dirait excusez-moi que des que
les
que le gouvernement n'est pas prêt qu'il
est brouillon qu'il cherche une majorité
qu'il cherche une ligne donc les
républicains ont pris leur
responsabilité et on vont proposer un
texte
identique pas de texte mais un texte
identique à l'Assemblée nationale comme
au Sénat avec les propositions concrètes
le Gouvernement présente un texte en
juillet bah oui elles ont une utilité
d'abord la première utilité ça a été de
l'annoncer donc le gouvernement qui
procrastinait sur cette question a été
obligée de commencer à assez mouvoir et
à proposer quelque chose et ensuite
parce que c'est ce que nous voterons on
sait ce qu'on va travailler on sait ce
qu'on veut pas parce que le texte qui
avait été proposé précédemment par
Emmanuel Macron via Olivier dussope et
Gérald Darmanin était un appel d'air on
n'est pas là aujourd'hui la situation
sur l'immigration est Catastro en France
je rappelle qu'il y a une hausse de 17%
des titres de séjour délivrés en 2002
par rapport à 2021 une hausse de 31,3%
des premières demandes d'asile avec bien
sûr les demandes d'asile la plupart ne
sont pas n'aboutissent pas mais les
personnes restent sur place une hausse
de 45 % de l'immigration économique et
une baisse de 35 % en nombre des mesures
d'éloignement exécutées par rapport à
2019 et la situation de Mayotte qui qui
montre aux Français l'impuissance
organisée de l'État en fait aujourd'hui
la France ne peut plus choisir qui reste
chez elle et qui vient chez elle y
compris quand des personnes viennent sur
notre sol en trichant voilà en donc
aujourd'hui il est urgent qu'on est un
texte ce texte sera
identique Assemblée nationale Sénat
c'est à dire Bruno retaillod Olivier
Marleix et Éric Ciotti c'est très
important et ensuite ce texte aura de
voler le premier la demande d'une
réforme constitutionnelle et la seconde
un texte sur l'immigration pour pouvoir
répondre aux attentes et aux souffrances
des Français parce que je crois que le
terme souffrance n'est vraiment un terme
approprié à la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur
l'immigration l'autre actualité c'est
hier soir l'Assemblée nationale qui va
donc créer la demande de la majorité une
commission d'enquête sur les
groupuscules auteurs de violence à
l'occasion des manifestations entre le
16 mars déclenchement du 49.3 et le 3
mai ça comprend donc les manifestations
de sainte Soline les manifestations du
1er mai c'est une bonne idée je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas rester dans
cette situation où on s'est parfaitement
les services
identifient les fauteurs de troubles je
pense qu'il faut les mettre hors d'état
de participer à des manifestations pour
casser donc il y a des choses qui
peuvent déjà être faites mais qui ne
sont pas encore faites et je pense qu'il
est urgent de faire en sorte que à
chaque manifestation on ne sait pas à
cette impuissance publique encore une
fois qui organisée et à ce chaos c'est
plus possible les policiers ne peuvent
pas être les cibles de ces personnes qui
veulent mettre fin à cette mauvaise
République pour reprendre ce terme
abominable employé par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ou qui sont là pour tuer du
flic ou taper du flic ce n'est plus
possible donc oui c'est une urgence
enfin on a déjà des moyens qui ne sont
pas utilisés comme ils sont d'enquête
c'est utile pourquoi pas pourquoi pas on
verra bien de toute façon mais déjà il y
a des moyens qui ne sont pas utilisés
mettant les en place Gérald Darmanin a
demandé au préfet d'interdire les
manifestations d'ultra-droites est-ce
que c'est la bonne décision est-ce qu'on
peut le faire bah écoutez on verra ce
que le Conseil constitutionnel dira et
quels sont
soit on interdit des manifestations
parce que elle porte un trouble à
l'ordre public je crois que c'était la
ligne
à partir du moment où ces manifestations
ne portent pas un trouble public le
ministre de l'Intérieur vaut changer la
loi donc voilà est-ce que c'est le
moment parce qu'il aurait fallu
interdire la manifestation du 6 mai
alors est-ce que ces images sont
choquées cette manipulation je suis
contre les manifestes je suis contre les
manifestations où les gens arrivent
masquer mais c'est quand même curieux de
sophusquer que des gens arrivent masquer
dans cette manifestation et pas dans
d'autres aujourd'hui dans d'autres
manifestations on a bien vu à
Sainte-Soline ailleurs les black-box etc
des personnes qui arrivent masquées il y
en a tout le temps donc
moi je n'ai aucune sympathie pour ce
type de manifestation mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut de la cohérence
aujourd'hui mais alors c'est sûr que ça
émule la gauche qui n'était pas émue
pour pour d'autres
écoutez l'important c'est qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui à faire en sorte qu'on cesse
cette espèce de
haine de des forces de l'ordre de
casseurs à chaque manifestation c'est
plus possible ça participe
à cette situation dans laquelle on est
on constate une impuissance publique
dans ce domaine encore une fois vous
avez apporté sur Twitter votre soutien à
Florence berger
cette chercheuse CNRS qui a vu la
Sorbonne reporter sa conférence en cas
de consacrée aux Frères musulmans sans
plus d'explications comment vous
l'expliquez vous alors j'ai fait plus
qu'apporter mon soutien je l'ai
rencontré nous avons discuté vous savez
la vie est compliquée pour elle parce
que
elle depuis que cette chercheuse du CNRS
a publié un ouvrage sur le frerisme
comme d'autres l'avaient publié je pense
à Alexandre Delval je pense à ce
chercheur Suisse qui a publié un projet
etc et bien
ils sont menacés elle est obligée de
vivre avec une protection policière
alors que ce sujet a été très peu
exploré d'ailleurs son livre est
passionnant et j'invite les auditeurs à
l'acheter à le lire
et donc elle elle dit un certain nombre
de choses qui sont essentielles à la
compréhension de notre société
aujourd'hui et effectivement l'empêche
de parler vous allez prendre une
initiative au Sénat on sa faveur est-ce
qu'il y aura quelque chose avant même
cette affaire c'est vrai que j'avais
proposé qu'on organise de nouveau une
une conférence j'avais j'écris au
président du Sénat et et à notre
président Bruno Retailleau pour qu'on
organise une conférence il y avait eu
lieu il y avait une conférence avec
quelques temps sur ce sujet je pense que
c'est nécessaire et important et dans
mon courrier je cite un certain nombre
de personnes dont dans cette chercheuse
bien évidemment
et on va
parler de votre actualité plus
particulièrement au sein puisque vous
êtes rapporteur d'un taxe qui a été
adopté hier pour garantir le respect du
droit à l'image des enfants on va voir
ce que contient ce texte avec Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour
et Audrey le Sénat a donc adopté il y a
une proposition de loi vision à mieux
protéger le droit à l'image des enfants
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment parce
que vous allez nous le dire Audrey les
chiffres sont aussi impressionnants que
glaçant est-ce que vous savez Oriane
qu'avant c'est 13 ans un enfant apparaît
en moyenne 1300 fois sur des
photographies des vidéos publiées en
ligne dans la majorité des cas ce sont
les parents et les proches qui postent
ces clichés alors sur le moment ça peut
paraître innocent mais ces photos
peuvent mettre l'enfant mal à l'aise
elles peuvent faire l'objet de
détournement de moqueries de harcèlement
scolaire voire bien pire on va écouter à
ce sujet le garde des sceaux qui
supporte cette proposition de loi
d'ici la fin de la décennie les
informations partagées en ligne par les
parents seront la première cause
d'usurpation d'identité pour leurs
enfants en 2020 50% des images qui
s'échangent sur les sites
pédopornographiques ont été initialement
publiés par les parents
50% le chiffre est glaçant un chiffre
qui s'explique notamment parce que les
parents ont des comptes publics dans
certains cas mais même quand ce compte
est privé un parent sur deux dit ne pas
connaître finalement tous les amis qu'il
a virtuellement alors il y a déjà eu un
texte en 2020 mais ça concernait
uniquement les enfants influenceurs
cette nouvelle proposition de loi qui
vient de l'assemblée a pour but
principal de créer une prise de
conscience chez les parents non ce n'est
pas anodin de poster une photo une vidéo
de son enfant en ligne voilà
les sénateurs Audrey ils ont enrichi ce
texte ils l'ont rendu plus objectifs oui
c'est vous qui avez porté qui avait été
la rapporteur de ce texte les enfants
les parents pardon ont désormais
obligations de veiller au respect de la
vie privée de leur enfant ce sera
désormais inscrit dans le Code civil il
faudra aussi l'accord des deux parents
avant de poster une photo ou une vidéo
de son enfant sur un compte public ça ne
concerne pas évidemment les boucles
familiales par exemple sur WhatsApp il y
en a beaucoup et enfin la CNIL pourra
demander le blocage d'un site qui ne
respecterait pas le droit et les
libertés d'un mineur même s'il n'y a pas
de caractère
urgent alors ce sont des mesures
consensuelles qui ont été portées par
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
médières la critique était ailleurs
contre le gouvernement vous et vos
collègues avaient dénoncé la manière de
légiférer puisqu'il y a actuellement
quatre textes qui concernent les enfants
et Internet quatre textes très
différents étudiés actuellement
législation véritablement protectrice ne
saurait se bâtir par la multiplication
de petites propositions de loi au champ
et à la portée limitée et dans les
objectifs non coordonnés pour être de
nature à nuire à la cohérence d'ensemble
dans notre droit ces initiatives
parlementaires sont certes les bienvenus
mais force est de constater qu'elles
sont partielles et parcellaires une fois
n'est pas coutume et nous semble que
pour faire preuve d'efficacité face à un
sujet aussi complexe l'outil était
préférable que l'exécutif prenne
l'initiative d'un projet de loi
transversal et globale vous le savez
monsieur le ministre pour rédiger des
projets de loi l'exécutif dispose de
moyens et d'expertise sont commune
mesure avec ceux dont disposent des
parlementaires ne serait-ce que pour
l'étude d'impact par exemple la dernière
initiative gouvernementale à sujet date
de 2016 quand on parle d'Internet
évidemment ça fait une éternité hier
vous avez demandé un grand plan une
politique publique du gouvernement à
sujet vous avez bon espoir qu'il s'en
empare d'abord je comprends l'intérêt de
ce texte comme de tous ceux qui sont
passés je rappelle quand même qu'on a
une proposition de roi relative à
l'exposition excessive des enfants à
l'écran qui reprend celles de Catherine
Morin de Saïd 2018 on a une proposition
de loi qui vise à instaurer une majorité
numérique que va présenter notre
collègue Alexandra borquio Fontain dans
quelques jours on a une la semaine
prochaine je crois on a une proposition
de loi qui vise en crédit l'influence
commerciale et lutter contre les dérives
des influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux
que le Sénat a adopté mardi soir et il y
avait ce texte qui nous vient de
l'Assemblée nationale sur le plan de
l'organisation je comprends qu'il faille
faire plaisir aux députés macronistes en
mal de popularité aujourd'hui sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres mais un moment
donné je pense qu'il est temps de
prendre nos responsabilités c'est voilà
le gouvernement cherche des sujets
consensuels je pense que ce sujet là est
consensuel et que à l'Assemblée
nationale comme au Sénat tout le monde
aurait été d'accord pour travailler sur
cette question là il nous arrive des
textes saucissonnés avec des redondances
des effets de tuilages qui ne sont pas
bons alors et moi je demande c'est vrai
que j'ai demandé trois choses la
première demande c'est les labors
rations d'un véritable programme de
santé publique ou à chaque âge de la
crèche au lycée il y a des
apprentissages des apprentissages
partagés par l'Éducation nationale alors
les associations font du très bon
travail mais je pense qu'à un moment
donné il ne faut pas confier ça à des
associations mais en faire un programme
où on parlerait de d'exposition aux
écrans de harcèlement de drogue de de
divers sujets d'hygiène de
d'alimentation tout ça sont des sujets
qui sont essentiels mais il faudrait
l'élaborer ensemble le ma demande aussi
c'est de c'est de créer et ça c'est du
domaine du législatif j'avais pu le
faire lorsque j'étais député j'avais
plus ouvrir dans dans la loi HPST un
livre dans le code de la santé publique
sur les troubles du comportement
alimentaire là nécessaire et
urgent d'ouvrir un livre dans le code de
la santé publique sur le numérique sur
l'accès au numérique qui parlerait en
gros pour simplifier mais il faudra
aller de façon beaucoup plus fine
une émission complète de l'exposition
des enfants aux écrans et de leur
exposition eux-mêmes sur les écrans
comme vous pouvez comme vous voulez le
dire souvent par les parents avec
beaucoup de bonnes volontés beaucoup
d'inconsciences et d'insouciance et
enfin il est temps aussi de faire en
sorte que ce document papier qui existe
encore qui est vraiment un document
formidable qui s'appelle le carnet de
santé on est une page complète sur les
écrans pourquoi parce que ça sert de
guide pour les parents pour les
éducateurs pour les médecins pour toutes
les personnes que les parents vont
rencontrer et ça sert aussi de garde-fou
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure ce sont
les parents qui poste ces images
y compris même pendant les images les
échographies donc sur des réseaux
sociaux et puis là aussi ces fameux
pranks vous savez ces blagues on en
avait vu une très très connue genre caca
Nutella qui mettent les enfants dans des
situations humiliantes dégradantes qui
portent atteinte à leur dignité ils
n'ont pas droit à l'oubli donc tout ça
il faut vraiment avertir les parents les
alerter ces pédagogiques et ça leur
permet de résister à la pression parce
que quand ils ont des enfants qui disent
mais tout le monde tout le monde peut
non dans le carnet de santé ce sera il
n'a pas été modifié depuis 2018 donc
voilà ce que je préconise et enfin pour
terminer sur le texte si vous le
permettez effectivement il y a une
mesure très importante
qui est celle d'avertir les parents de
mettre fin à cette sorte d'insouciance
qui existe aujourd'hui avec ses
publications mais aussi de de les
alerter sur ces dangers il n'y a aucune
urgence aucune urgence jamais à publier
la photo de son enfant sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà les réseaux sociaux c'est
pas la boucle familiale effectivement en
termes pratiques peut-être quand vous
demandez l'accord des deux parents
comment on le met en place
on le met en place des gens en faisant
prendre conscience aux parents on les
informant par les modifications qu'il y
a dans le Code civil et surtout en
agissant sur le domaine qui est
réglementaire c'est ça qui compte
aujourd'hui et vous savez en cas de
conflit entre les parents les images
seront utilisées je pense que c'est une
prise de conscience de ce texte qui est
important et c'est pour ça que je
regrette qu'on ait travaillé de cette
façon parce que ça aurait mérité que les
Français sachent que le Parlement dans
son ensemble s'empare de ce sujet sur un
sujet global et important et là c'est
vraiment dommage merci
je vais parler d'un autre texte le texte
sur les influenceurs justement que vous
avez
est-ce qu'il y a dans ce texte et
comment s'est passé la séance merci
beaucoup Audrey à tout à l'heure là
aussi un examen global on en parle tout
à l'heure dans le club on va aller chez
vous à Marseille Valérie Boyer on
retrouve les hauts plurguettes bonjour
Léo merci d'être avec nous président et
directeur éditorial du Journal La
Marseillaise Léo vous souhaitiez revenir
sur un gros dossier publié dans vos
pages sur la question du logement
oui tout à fait puisque après nos
révélations de lundi sur l'insuffisance
de construction de logements sociaux
depuis trois ans
l'adjointe à l'urbanisme a décidé de
rendre sa démission et le maire de
Marseille répond à nos questions dans
l'édition d'aujourd'hui
il nous dit notamment que il n'est pas
satisfait de cette situation et comment
il souhaite redressé là-bas il nous dit
aussi que alors qu'il a été l'objet de
critique et maintenant de la droite il
préférait qu'elle présente ses excuses
plutôt que de donner des leçons compte
tenu de son bilan alors je vous ai
demandé à la sénatrice Boyer qui a été
adjointe au logement pendant l'ergaudens
ce qu'elle pensait de ce dossier
d'abord j'ai pas été adjointe au
logement lorsque j'étais adjoint au
maire de Jean-Claude Gaudin mais j'étais
adjointe à la politique de la ville à la
rénovation urbaine c'est-à-dire que je
m'occupais des projets en rue et j'étais
présidentE du Jeep politique de la ville
je pense que c'est un dossier qui est
extrêmement délicat la situation que
nous avons à Marseille vous savez c'est
aussi le résultat de cette fameuse loi
SRU qui à mon sens doit être changé et
lorsque vous êtes quota de logements et
qui impose des quotas de logements
sociaux et surtout qui ne permet pas aux
maires d'avoir la maîtrise de leur
logement social parce que c'est ça aussi
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation on
a une crise du logement dans toute la
France et on l'a dénoncé à plusieurs
reprises cette crise du logement elle
est en train d'arriver je rappelle que
il semblerait qu'à Marseille il y a
37000 logements non rénovés il y a 17000
demandes de logement qui ne sont pas
pourvues et il faut en moyenne entre 5
et 7 ans pour obtenir un logement social
sachant qu'il n'y a aucun turn over il
n'y a pas de de modification de rotation
merci dans le logement social donc ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
catastrophique vous savez il en va dans
le logement social qui n'a jamais eu
pour vocation d'être un logement à vie
ni de séries de génération en génération
le logement social c'était pour faire
face
une situation et après permettre
aux personnes qui en bénéficié aux
Français qui en bénéficié de pouvoir
rentrer dans un parcours résidentiel
comme on dit je pense qu'il en va
effectivement du logement social comme
il en va du RSA je veux dire c'est pas
une situation pour s'installer dans une
politique publique mais c'était fait
pour aider aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation différente et on est aussi
avec une loi SRU qui qui
est punitive pour des villes qui n'ont
pas de foncier ou qui ont des
difficultés et qui sont mises à l'amande
parce que elle n'arrive pas à remplir
leur quota alors la difficulté
effectivement pour la majorité un petit
peu baroque de la ville de Marseille
c'est qu'ils avaient fait du logement
une priorité et que ami mandat on voit
qui s'est pas passé grand chose moi j'ai
plusieurs interrogations quelle est la
politique du logement à Marseille comme
en France pour le gouvernement pour les
travailleurs pauvres pour les
travailleurs pour les familles
pour ceux qui ont un emploi difficile
parce que ça c'est une vraie question on
l'a vu récemment à Paris où on a appris
qu'il y avait des points donc
qui défavorisait totalement et qui ont
fait en sorte que les familles la classe
moyenne et les les ouvriers les
travailleurs à petit salaire sont
chassés de de de Paris donc où on en est
pour toutes ces questions et comment on
fait pour faire évoluer la loi SRU et
maintenant effectivement je pense qu'il
y a loin des promesses qui ont été
tenues par par la majorité actuelle à
Marseille au réalisation c'est une
réalité et c'est vrai qu'à mi-mandat
c'est un cataclysme pour la majorité de
Benoît paillant qui je le rappelle a été
mise à mal par notre par notre collègue
pour pour la façon dont il recouvrait
l'impôt qui est mise à mal pour le
logement social qui est mis à mal aussi
pour ses promesses sur les écoles
Léo vous allez nous parler d'un autre
sujet actualité international puisque
vous allez nous parler de la
présidentielle en Turquie dimanche 14
mai
puisque elles sont elles sont couplées
avec les élections parlementaires je
sais que Madame Boyer vous vous
intéressez beaucoup à ce pays et je
voulais avoir votre point de vue sur
l'instabilité qui peut surgir de ces
élections croyez-vous que l'air Erdogan
et on passe de se terminer et si c'était
le cas craignez-vous des troubles
alors pour la première je ne sais pas je
sais que les Turcs sont très inquiets
qu'ils ont peur des triches qu'il que la
situation est très difficile que
l'opposition est muselée et
qu'effectivement c'est très compliqué
pour ceux qui aiment la liberté la
démocratie en Turquie c'est une réalité
oui effectivement je pense que c'est la
Turquie est un facteur d'instabilité
majeur pour elle-même mais aussi pour
l'Union européenne et pour toute la zone
vous savez que elle occupe depuis 1974
un pays de l'Union européenne qu'elle
menace la Grèce très régulièrement et je
ne sais pas ce qui sortira des urnes si
même si les oppositions à Récept à
hiberdogan quand bien même elle pourrait
gagner que je ne sais pas est-ce que
aucun observateur d'ailleurs ne
s'accorde
n'a d'idée sur la façon dont le scrutin
va pouvoir se dérouler
est-ce que ce serait mieux pour la
démocratie est-ce que ce serait mieux
pour l'Union européenne est-ce que ce
serait mieux pour l'horreur qui est en
train de se dérouler dans l'indifférence
internationale pour l'Arménie et le
Karaba aujourd'hui où on en est à plus
de 150 jours de blocage et d'étouffement
et avec une politique génocide d'air qui
ne se cache plus soutenu par la Turquie
et mise en œuvre par l'Azerbaïdjan
honnêtement aujourd'hui j'en sais rien
on regarde tout ça avec attention mais
aussi avec avec une certaine peur parce
que ça peut avoir des conséquences sur
le chaos migratoire qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui il y a déjà eu des menaces
d'Erdogan est-ce que ces concurrents
auront une politique différente pour
pour le chantage migratoire je ne sais
pas visiblement non est-ce qu'ils auront
une politique différente sur les îles
grecques non est-ce qu'ils ont une
politique différente pour Chypre non
donc on voit que le problème est
extrêmement important aujourd'hui pour
la Turquie et
difficile aussi pour les Turcs qui
souffrent pour ceux qui sont démocrates
de la situation dans laquelle il se
trouve aujourd'hui avec une situation
économique extrêmement dégradée aussi en
Turquie puisque je crois que le 10 du
mois y compris les personnes qui
travaillent en tout cas n'arrivent plus
à faire face
à même à l'alimentation donc la
situation est assez tendue
[Musique]
c'est Benoît paillan le maire de
Marseille ont réussi à sur le logement
comme pour les écoles voilà ce que dit
Benoît Paillon une de la Marseillaise
merci Léo kurgate d'avoir été avec nous
et merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on parlera du
texte voté au Sénat pour encadrer les
pratiques des influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux et mieux protéger les
victimes des bases suivre mais d'abord
on va retrouver Carole Delga notre
invité dans quelques secondes
merci